it's damn bull has a new airport its
scale is breathtaking and reflects the
Turkish government's ambitions for it to
become a hub capable of rivaling the
likes of Dubai and Abu Dhabi by the end
of this year it will have three runways
and will be able to handle 90 million
passengers although that will rise to
200 million a year once fully complete
Rajee a's airport's chief executive is
in london to sign an exclusive hotel
management deal with the hotel and she
dray Samson Lew joins me now very good
evening to you Istanbul already has two
airports what does it need another one
well the Ataturk Airport which is
located in the European side of the city
is very constrained in terms of capacity
on the runway as well as on the terminal
and the flagship carrier of Turkey
Turkish airline has very aggressive
growth growth program and infrastructure
is not able to keep keep up with it
therefore the government as a part of
the liberalization efforts in the
country in the last 15 years it
conducted a tender for a brand new
airport with significant room for growth
and now that's why we are going to have
a new airport with new facility new
runways a new terminal so it will be
able to service the flagship carrier as
well as all the international carriers
who want to get a slot in Turkey to
increase their frequencies and this is
cost something like 11 billion u.s.
dollars how long is the payback for the
Turkish government going to be Turkish
court pays nothing because it's a PPP
program which is basically all the
financial obligations is a student by my
sponsors and all the investment will be
made by them and then we are also going
to pay on top a concession fee for 25
years and after 25 years the asset will
be returned back to the back to the
government but in terms of the return
for the Turkish economy you think that
would that return we generated very
immense I mean a contribution to Turkish
economy once we completed all those four
phases the contribution to the GDP is
going to be around 5% we are going to be
increasing the employment around 200,000
people and contribution to the GDP is
going to be some around 1440 billion
euro and by how long do you expect to
build the railway connection from the
airport into the city centre it
already under construction unfortunately
on the scheduled opening day which is
our Republic Day on the 29th of October
the metro want the tube is won't be
ready but in the first half of next year
it's going to be ready and it's going to
be something similar to London London
Heathrow Express with only four stops in
the downtown city I'll be one base
expensive is a heater Express now you've
had quite a few fatalities building this
Airport I think something like 27 in all
what was that well half of them were
natural debt and and there has been some
car ACCI I mean the accident car
accidents in the construction site as a
result of which around 12 people I mean
passed away so and another 14 people
were just natural that so to be
absolutely clear you squarely in this in
your sights here at Dubai and Abu Dhabi
you're looking to become a gateway
between the East and the West
but is this more about getting people
into Turkey or is it about allowing
Turkish people to see the rest of the
world well it is bought actually meeting
Eastern West is more qualified for
Turkey because historically we are on
the on the very important trade routes
between East and West and now we are we
are reviving this story and this Disney
this new airport is going to be hop not
only for Turks but mean it for for for
people living in five continents because
the flagship carrier Turkish airline
flies everywhere in this in this context
we just heard from example from Qantas
during the direct flight from London to
Perth it's the hub model still relevant
in this day and age when you've got
these big planes that are capable of
flying point-to-point
over long distances well the issue is
you need you need to gather people from
from each all destinations and bring
them to the hop and from from from that
location you distribute them wherever
wherever they want to go in four hours
distance around Istanbul there are 200
destinations
60 capitals so that requires some kind
of hopping
which is going to be more appealing and
much cheaper transportation means for
everybody
very very briefly president Irwin's
called an election today was that
exactly a surprise to the business
community
well elections are called in every
democratic nations we are going to be
heading towards an early election
I hope the outcome of the election is
going to do the best for us and for the
world all right should write some sort
of appreciate you joining me thanks for
coming in